[Music]
chuck always good to
have you as my co-host there thanks for
being there always good to be here man
and we're going to talk about uh the the
neuroscience of learning
and neither you nor i have any such
expertise
so we we got to go to our go-to person
in this dr heather berlin heather
welcome back to star talk
thanks it's always a pleasure to be here
with you yeah and this is
star talk at the science is cool virtual
unconference and who knows how many
countries are represented here and i'm
delighted
it's a reminder that it is one world and
education is a thing that we all care
about
and so or at least of us most of us
and so it's a little hyperbolic to say
we all care
let's remember we are we are beaming out
from america
but we have teachers care and teachers
of the primary audience here so for sure
we got 100 of them uh of those who care
uh and heather let me just finish your
your your
your bio here so you're a neuroscientist
and clinical
psychologist and assistant professor of
psychiatry
at the icon school of medicine at mount
sinai
uh mount sinai hospital in new york is
that did i get that right yes indeed
that's all it is that's it sorry that's
all
that's all it is
[Laughter]
all right so heather let me just start
off um by saying
when we learn something new what happens
in our brains to either learn it
first you know to to to climb the wall
or the barrier to learn it and then to
retain it
what change happens in our brain for
that to take place
yeah i mean so learning is actually a
physical change in the brain and the
best way to
remember this is there's a saying we
have a neuroscience cells that fire
together
wire together what
look at the brain going all hip-hop
brain is just having happy hours and
just
okay you know that's what it is so once
you sort of you make a connection
the more you rehearse it that's what
studying is about the more you go over
something over and over again
you're actually teaching these neurons
to fire together and then they regrow
they grow new receptors
so that the next time it's stimulated
it's easier
to uh make that connection so you're
actually developing
new neural pathways that are firing
quicker in your brain
that's what learning is well but some
people will remember something forever
upon learning at once and others have to
keep being reminded of it so what's the
difference there
one of them is green chemicals i believe
the difference is one of them is stupid
[Laughter]
see neil there's there's smart people
and then there's not so smart people
okay chuck you were reminding us why we
have an actual neuroscientist on the
show
to give us to tell us what what actually
what's really going on okay i mean okay
they're the very very rare people that
have you know what
what they say is like a you know they
can see something immediately remember
it but
for the average person that can happen
usually when it's tied to something
either personally significant to them
um or when they learn it it's involved
with um a lot of emotions
are being stimulated at that time
because emotions
tag memories and if you think about it
what is learning learning is really
forming a memory
right learning is is intimately linked
to memory and so emotions
tag memories as important so we call
those flash bulb memories so
we'll remember you know where we wait
heather no one knows what a flash bulb
is
no one under 30. so please tell us what
a flash bulb is
oh there are these old-fashioned cameras
thank you
thank you good evening mr and mrs
america and all the simpsons see
you ever and you see them in these you
know period pieces um
where they would flash a light bulb
really quickly and the light bulbs
actually would then
go out because it was so bright i guess
and that's timed with the
photograph they're taking so the the the
instant the flash
occurs the exposure in the camera opens
up
so that the scene is lit up for the film
because the film
was not sensitive enough to light to
just use
ambient light and you needed the flash
okay so there we go there you go
so but it's this idea of taking a very
momentary imprint and then it just kind
of
stays permanently and usually when
there's an emotion involved that tells
the brain hey this is something pretty
important you should remember it
um so when you're that's experiential
but when you're learning if things are
tied to emotion if they're personally
significant they sort of get ingrained
into your neural network in a different
kind of way and that's why they say
to learn things better you should tag
them to things that you already know
so wait a minute so on on star talk um
we have
chuck who is occasionally funny
yes kind of like an eclipse
i'm just i'm funny like an eclipse
rarely no no chuck we have chuck because
our
intuitions tell us that if you
laugh while you're learning that's an
important
associated emotion the the joy
that gets attached to this bit of
knowledge that you just acquired
and we tell ourselves but you can affirm
this or deny it
that that enhances people's not only
appreciation for what they've learned
but the longevity of of uh it's duration
in your head
thereafter exactly well the thing about
humor is that
it activates um the reward system in the
brain and releases this
neurochemical dopamine and dopamine
actually enhances both your motivation
and long-term memory so
as long as you can activate it has to be
the right kind of humor though studies
show that if it's inappropriate
humor or maybe just not that funny it
doesn't work as well for learning
but why are you why you got it why you
got to do me like that
i was feeling i was feeling all good i'm
like chuck nice is part of the
dopaminergic system
what is going on oh this is great and
then you're like gotta qualify it like
oh but it's got to be the right kind of
the right kind of computer it's not just
any old chuckstock
you can't but
yeah i mean so but in a sense if you can
if you can um stimulate those
neurochemicals in the brain people
remember better also
humor tends to tie things to to imagery
to stories and again you're activating
the larger neural network
instead of just learning wrote facts you
have a context in which
you can embed that information and then
you'll remember it better
is this similar to when people say the
smell
immediately brought back an entire
graphic memory of some trip they took
that smell being a sort of a sensory
feeder to your capacity to remember
absolutely i mean smells are
it's one of our primary senses because
it's the only sense actually that goes
straight to the cortex the other senses
go through something called the thalamus
which is like a relay station in the
brain and then it sends it
to the cortex but smell is is very
direct it's a very primitive um primary
sense and most of it is happening
unconsciously
which by the way i just might add is why
doing everything over
video and zoom we're losing some
information particularly olfactory
information well i'm going to get to
that that's going to make that a whole
other segment of this but
let me work my way there so can you um
what's the difference between learning
something that's
already known and creativity
in sort of creating something that no
one has
thought to do or think before
so this is something i'm really
interested in on creativity so
how i define it is kind of is making
novel associations between ideas
making connections that other people
haven't seen before but in order to do
that you need to first take in all of
the facts
all the information so if you look at
someone say like darwin's theory of
evolution
he had to take in all the information
did all the research
and then based on that basic information
or data
came up with a new way to connect it all
in this
kind of theory that well maybe the mark
but other people didn't think of before
in in that way right and so that i think
is creativity
is coming up with novel ideas based on
what everybody else knows but no one
thought of before and by the way usually
when somebody comes up with it everyone
goes
oh yeah of course that's so obvious but
yet nobody else thought of it
so this is a common definition of genius
where they say a genius
is the person that sees what everyone
else has seen but
thinks what no one else has thought and
so that's an interesting way but then if
that's the source of our creativity that
argues for learning as much as you can
so that you have the so at least you
have the capacity
right to to connect to re-stitch it
together because without it you got
you've got no foundations for being a
genius with is that a fair
way to put absolutely i think all sort
of geniuses
or when they say they have these flashes
of insight you know it doesn't come out
of nowhere
they've actually put in the work they've
put in the time they've collected all
the information and then usually
most of what happens is happening
unconsciously outside of awareness which
is why
sleep is very important for coming up
with new ideas because the brain is
consolidating the information but you
have to put in the work
take in the information let your brain
mull it over and then
come up with these great insights can i
tell a quick story when i was in college
um and i well in calculus
all right probably most kids out there
who are listening haven't had calculus
yet
but you will if you or you should
calculus is
a brilliant branch of mathematics very
advanced but
there's a rule in calculus called
l'hopital's rule
lahapital and it's almost spelled like
hospital but
patal hopital's rule and it is invoked
in calculus
it's a very simple rule it's it's
deceptively simple
and i'd never heard of this guy la patal
before all right
and i'm in the depths of my college's
library
the math library and then i i'm just
you know meandering and i come upon a
shelf
and the shelf must have been two
meters wide and it was the collected
works
of la habital and i thought to myself
i don't know any of the rest of this
work but i know this one
simple rule that applies to all of what
we do in calculus
so then i thought to myself did it
really take that much
life's investment in thinking about this
problem
to come up with that one of the simplest
rules that calculus knows
i mean i think the answer is yes right
um but
you know even if you want to explain
something in the simplest way
um usually that's the hardest part to do
right the easiest part in a sense is
collecting all the information
being able to simplify it and unify it
under one
let's say that's a whole other thing
that's another number but you know what
the other yeah oh sorry go on now you're
like no no no no no no no no you're the
expert here i'm not yeah
but before you go any further i was
going to say i was going to ask
is there anything that you can do
mechanisms
that you can use for these for the
teachers that are listening to
rules of simplification like that make
learning easier
what what what what you just said about
making things calling it down to where
it's something that's so
digestible are there any rules that make
our brains receive information
more easily hmm i would say
yes but maybe in a slightly different
way i think
so i was talking about dopamine and how
dopamine is motivating right
and one thing that we know is that
curiosity
activates these reward networks and if
you could motivate kids to
just get them curious about the topic
or the information that will drive them
like why did neil go
and start looking through the books in
the library like he was motivated by
something maybe he was curious and
that's what drives
you want the motivation to be coming
internally to learn
not oh you need to learn this so you can
you know
or else yeah or else right right but so
so that's
that drive to come internally yeah that
that dovetails beautifully with i think
an
important question here especially for
this conference
what do we know about all that's been
said about different
types of learners right there are people
who
need to experience it to learn it or to
read it or to
what what is known about this because
there's so much written
and but what does a neuroscientist say
well you know this is a actually a myth
that's been perpetrated for many years
and it's very hard to break
so although there are different um
types of you know this idea of different
intelligences some people are more
you know visual and or auditory or they
have more kinesthetic abilities
kinesthetic would be uh movement or
physical body
engagement yeah
yes there are individual differences in
terms of those abilities
however when you do a meta-analysis
which is basically looking across a
whole group of many studies
and seeing what the kind of final
results are
teaching styles did not make a
difference
and did not in terms of trying to tailor
a teaching style to a
specific ability didn't change how the
students learned
so the idea that tailoring a teaching
method toward students particular
abilities isn't necessarily
going to make them learn the information
better which is interesting
however there are certain individual
differences that do matter
some people are better learning
independently they want to be kind of
left alone just give me the
you know the books and i'll do it on my
own others need a more structured
um approach and they need more
scaffolding or help along the way
so those different learning styles yes
but not the ones that
in that kind of traditional sense of
like oh he's a visual learner she's an
auditory learner but wait i
when i think of science museums some of
them are very focused on sort of kinetic
exhibits where the levers and buttons
and and
you sort of set the class loose into
the exhibit floor and there they go
and you know if that's a different
experience than setting them loose in a
room of books
okay i i'm thinking if i'm gonna learn
something i'm gonna go to the museum
floor first and that might excite me and
maybe later i'll open a book
but i to so i'm it doesn't
ring true what you're saying it sounds
to me
like it sounds to me wait heather just
because i'm i'm seen i'm excited now
it sounds to me like they are the
connective tissue of the learning
process
like what neil is talking about is what
leads to the curiosity that you were
talking about that creates this internal
drive
to learn so you start off pulling levers
and pushing buttons but what that does
is it incites you
internally so that when you're in the
room of books you now want to know
okay i'm with that i'll go with that
heather what do you think of that yeah
so what i was going to say is different
than the idea of different learning
styles
i think across the board having
experiential learning is always best if
you can do something
hands-on and get somebody involved in a
real world
scenario situation tie the information
you know that
often kids say oh what does this have to
do with the real world you know why do i
have to learn this calculus
nonsense right but if you have a real
world problem whether it's hands-on
or trying to figure something out that
you're dealing with in your everyday
life
that opens up like chuck said the doors
of curiosity
right but but then to chuck's point what
we're really saying and
i remember i work in a museum so i think
about this a lot
and and i don't always embrace
the concept in every exhibit or at least
the intent
so not to get into the weeds here but
there are many exhibits where you know
they're official educators and they're
there and they're analyzing it they say
well what is the principle of this
exhibit and what's
what idea you want to convey and and
then they test the person before
and after the exhibit to see what
they've learned and i'm saying people
they're spending four minutes in front
of this exhibit
whereas they spend hours and hours days
and days weeks and weeks months and
months in your classroom
so what what burden are you putting upon
the exhibit design for it to do your
teaching
maybe instead because if you fail at
that then the exhibit's got nothing
going for it
but if instead get it to chuck's point
if the exhibit just simply excited you
and even if you got no learned testable
knowledge from it if you say
oh my gosh these colors are amazing now
let me go learn more
yes i think that that is going to entail
a restructuring of the entire education
system
[Laughter]
out there but if
if instead oh so i'll give you an exam
can i just give an example and you were
talking about emotions
all right again i have a museum outlook
on this but of course
museum trips are common for schools so
but you get to hear this at least
firsthand um
i uh people who visited for example
the museum of science and industry in
chicago
and i said did you go as a kid yeah and
i'll say what was your favorite exhibit
there
okay and i'll write down in advance what
i already know
will have been their favorite exhibit
the exit
yes
but wait i i want to keep you in
suspense just briefly there's another
museum
in philadelphia here in the united
states the franklin institute named for
benjamin franklin
a famous scientist who on the side was
one of the founding fathers of the
united states
um he uh and it's named in his honor
i i say what was your favorite exhibit
there as a kid
i will write it down and i get the right
answer 100 of the time
okay people go to the the exploratorium
in san francisco and i'll say what was
your favorite exhibit i'll write it down
every time i've done this experiment i
get the right answer because
all right you know what they were so
museum of science and industry it was
the
coal mine exhibit where you go into a
shaft and
it's that at the at the at the franklin
institute
it's the living heart i don't know if
these exhibits are still there they're
living
chuck you're from philadelphia and the
heart is the bomb
okay you walk in and the inside
they've got the speakers and you feel
the pumping okay
and it's exploratorium a whole room of
exhibits but i know which one people
remembered
it's the one where they create a tornado
that's the size of the room
okay and in each one of those cases
you're not coming away
saying i now know the the thermodynamics
and the
and the fluid mechanics of a tornado no
but you want to know about tornadoes
all right and the same with the coal
mine and the same with the heart so
these are things that are that are
bigger than you are
is it true they had to shut down the
coal mine exhibit because little kids
kept getting black lung
again these are old memories and i
haven't checked on them lately but
heather i'm just putting in your lab
the idea that these are exhibits that i
don't think
the goal was to to
give someone an exam to see what they
learned after the exhibit and
but they created an indelible memory in
everyone who's experienced it
so i think one of the reasons why is
that we are all
born natural scientists right and
that is how we naturally evolve to learn
and
by experiencing things in the world this
whole school system was set up after the
fact right
but the way our brains work is to have
experiences
in the world and be naturally curious
and learn from them
and we are driven by we get like a high
a reward by getting an answer to a
question so neil to be very meta here
the way you just set up that whole
scenario and then i knew the best you
know exhibit here and hear it here and
we are on baited breath waiting for like
what's the answer right but that
is that's what learning is it's like set
it up set it up and we are natural
of curiosity will come through we want
to
have answers to questions we find
ourselves in this world around us
we're trying to make sense of it when a
lot of it is chaotic
you know what before we understood
weather patterns people were trying to
find connections to try to predict when
the rain was going to come
and that's how we naturally experience
the world from the day we're born and so
neil these
you know exhibitions that bring you put
you into these big world you're inside a
heart you know it's larger than you are
and you're trying to understand and
figure it out
that's one of the best ways to learn and
remember can i just say that
what what what you are wait wait chuck
you agreed with me as a native of
philadelphia that that's just
absolutely listen without a doubt i mean
i
at the the the heart in the franklin
institute and the franklin institute was
a place that i went
many many many times as a kid and it's a
shame because i know
that now there are school systems that
don't fund field trips because they
don't have the money
and i know that that's something that
happens now throughout the nation
where they have stripped this ability
for schools to get in a bus
and go somewhere with the kids and take
them out of the classroom
and put them in an immersive environment
where they are stimulated on
every single sense in every single way
and heather i
i read this and i was like yes this is
true
that as adults we remember
school trips long
after they have occurred you remember
school trips even when you don't even
remember the name of the teacher who
took you on the school trip
there's something about leaving the
school environment
and then absorbing an entire other world
out there and then returning this would
happen if you visited a planetarium
all right because you can't do that
necessarily in a classroom
so just to echo chuck's point so what
about this
heather from a neurological standpoint
experientially
can we achieve at least a close
facsimile to some of this stuff
with like um what's that oculus or
whatever that thing you put on your face
oh
virtual reality thank you virtual
reality yeah is it
nor logically are are we close to it
yeah so a couple things just to to make
a point a finer point on this there are
two types of memory
and one is sort of called semantic
memory which is the memory of knowledge
of facts
you know just taking in the information
and then there's call
what's called episodic memory which is
you're
remembering your experiences and you
know that's going on the trip
remembering the bus ride remembering and
then along the way you learn some facts
but they're tied into your experience
and those are two different memory
systems in the brain
that's an important thing to know if
you're designing a school system oh my
gosh
well well to this point of virtual
reality uh we
just before we go to q a because i'm
trying to hear what dave brings to us
from the larger audience
but we've just we are still kind of in a
pandemic
year where almost all learning had to
now take place
through a video screen or through
through a computer screen
and is that
there people pre i think who struggled
with that
could you comment on the difference
between learning from a human being or
an image of a human being even if it's a
live image
they're not there in flesh and blood
versus someone who's sitting in the room
with you can you
think about that difference in your
field absolutely you know so a lot of it
has to do with
again how our brains evolve to
communicate and so and socialize
and when we're in these kind of 2d zoom
worlds
first of all we're not making direct eye
contact right i'm sort of looking
at you and my screen but not looking at
you if i'm looking into the camera right
so we're not communicating in that way
there's something a little off our brain
recognizes that
we're not picking up on odors we're not
picking up on body motions all this
information
that's coming in unconsciously is
helping us learn it's helping us pay
attention
right because i you're in that virtual
world but then i can look behind me and
i'm in a whole different world over here
and there's a kind of separation between
us we're not embodied in the same space
which i think is meaningful
but that being said i think there are
ways in which there are some advantages
with the virtual learning you know you
can create
um kind of video gamification you know
you can socialize learning in those ways
if you
use it in creative ways it could be
beneficial or at least
supplement in person learning that's a
very important point heather what you're
saying
not to put words in your mouth but
actually i am aren't you you're saying
that if the moment we all got pushed to
zoom
classes all right if you did that
trying to do exactly what you previously
did
in real life it's bound to fail in some
fundamental ways if instead you say
here's a different way of interacting
with my students
how can i best exploit that those tools
rather than try to mimic something that
isn't this at all is that a fair way to
say that
exactly you know obviously with the
pandemic it happened so quickly that
there was no time to kind of recalibrate
right
but i think you know as we can now
maybe in retrospect and now that we have
time on our hands a little bit more
we can start developing the online uh
tools that we have in better ways so
it's not for the next pandemic
for the next concept obviously yes so
we'll be more prepared
of course
oh damn well let's let's see what what
dave is going to bring to us
uh from the the greater universe of the
world dave come on on
i i tell you there's too many good
questions let's dive into them there's
some really great
ones and um i'm gonna there's a
there's a lot of questions about
dopamine and i'm gonna rephrase it an
interesting way because we
before we started uh the little group
here was having a chat about classical
music
and i i think it's well known that
beethoven composed while he was walking
was was that because did the dopamine
help him
or was the activity or was there some
connection
with that yeah they're people who have
habits that they associate with
creative moments that's a if you if you
generalize that inquiry
that's an interesting question yeah i
mean i think with
exercise number one you're getting more
blood to the brain
you know you're getting more oxygen to
the brain so it always helps with
cognition and thinking
but the other thing with let's say going
for walks or getting outside
no one ever really did anything great
locked in a closet
is that what you're saying starved of
oxygen
that's not yes that's not the best place
to
come up with your creative ideas however
um
what what i think is really um important
is that
when you go out for a walk or go do
something physical
in a way you're shutting off a certain
network you're kind of not thinking
you're letting your mind go you're
letting it kind of be free and
unconstrained
right when you're kind of thinking about
trying to memorize something or taking
information
you're having that very um convergent
thinking you're limited but when you
kind of let go and let your mind go
that's when again these novel
associations between ideas can come and
the inspiration
and the thought so sometimes just
literally getting out there and being
physical
forces you to not think like when you
have writer's block or you're stuck
get up go for a walk go play tennis go
mountain climbing
and you might it might unblock you in
that way and so i think a lot of these
great philosophers and musicians and
creative people
would go for nietzsche would go for
walks all the time and he would come up
with his ideas as well so
i think there is something to that
excellent dave what else you got
yeah there's a really good related
question this is from uh
wilder pertl and he's asking from where
where are these
um let's see if we can find the chat but
um so there is this model model he calls
it abk i've seen
vark where it's visual auditory uh
reading writing and kinesthetic
but he's saying that well does maybe the
different styles just mix it up and make
the learning more interesting
and that's what we're we're seeing
so it cuts the monotony of whatever else
you'd be doing yeah so
today we'll do visual then later we're
gonna do auditory and then later we're
gonna do hands-on
what do you think of that heather i like
that a lot because i think it has more
to do with um
the novelty so the thing with dopamine
that gets it going is change
novelty and that keeps so if somebody's
just drowning on that classic like
bueller
you know that you guys will get that
reference favoritism
there's this really drone like boring
teacher and he's like bueller
fueler and it's just mundane but that's
not a great way to learn
but the changing it up different
activities you know today we're gonna do
this tomorrow we're doing something else
keeps it fresh keeps it exciting and by
the way that actor was a former
actual former speechwriter for richard
nixon by the way
yeah well that makes sense
his name is ben stein ben stein ben
stein is actually entertaining comedian
can i can i ask you this from cynthia
well oh no oh chuck is checking out the
questions too oh my god go for a check
go for it so how are you
or harry dude really did you misspell
your name
justinian uh i don't know how to spell
universe first name
okay so he says how good is iq at
predicting your intelligence
can a medium iq provided it works hard
do the same thing as somebody with a 140
plus first of all
is iq a real thing so not really so
so you know iq what we do when i measure
somebody's abilities we're looking at
different cognitive abilities
so somebody might be really good in sort
of visual spatial
processing some maybe might be good at
memory um at verbal abilities there are
all these different kinds of abilities
everybody has a different what we call a
neurocognitive profile
like a thumb print right different areas
of specialist
better abilities than others and then
this iq score
is like taking all of these different
abilities and trying to average it all
together into this one
sort of number which i find is
it doesn't it's not very meaningful
right unless it's at the extremes
so you know when you have somebody who
has um
severe a mental disability and they're
you know three or
standard deviations below the norm then
you know that is a good indicator
that they might need special help or or
whatever it may be and then again if you
have
say three standard deviations above the
norm these people are are going to need
maybe more enriched
teaching programs right because their
brains are working a little bit
differently so i think it's okay
for like a kind of indicator at the
extremes
but other than that you know the
difference between a 1
15 iq and a 120 or what you know it does
it's kind of meaningless or one you know
30. so
so i take it with a grain of salt can i
add to that heather because i've done
a fair amount of thinking on this topic
not from a neuroscientist perspective
but just as a person
who enjoys academics and learning in
other words
i'm not sure if you've noticed but i'm
i'm kind of smart
[Laughter]
so why is joyce learning yeah
i've never looked at this from a
neurological solution but
you know speaking as one of the world's
most foremost science educators
no no so here's my point i have
this is this is a true fact i've never
had an iq test in my life i attended
public schools
in new york city my whole life they do
not administer iq tests
in public schools the way they often do
in private schools
and i thought about it and i said i'm
glad
i don't know my iq score because if
it were low and i knew that early on
what would that have done to my
ambitions what would
what would i have said or you know i
really like the universe no but my iq
says i'll never do it
so i'll take up something else. and then
i thought suppose it's really high
and then i said yeah i couldn't do
anything and then like how well how
would that
what would that do to my relationship to
other people and my attitudes
towards them and my that would it would
turn me into a
you know to an obnoxious and and so i
just worried
what force it would have
on who and what i would become so i said
i don't care
i don't care i will be where my
ambitions take me
and i can tell you this that iq does not
code
for ambition and for me ambition is what
drives this world
and i can also tell you this only smart
people say they don't care what their iq
is
i'm i just didn't want any
person placed thing or number
to get between me and what i wanted to
become in life
that's all i'm saying and you know
that people who have whatever challenges
they do they can have ambitions that can
get them much farther than
anyone would have said they would would
have gone and let me tell this just
while we're here
i might have said this on have we done
this five times already dave or
something let me just
if i said it before i'm saying it again
all right in my
k through 12 kindergarten through high
school
and all the teachers i've ever had none
of them would have pointed to me in
their class and say
hey he he'll go far watch for him
he's gonna none of them none of them
meanwhile i've known since i was nine
years old that i wanted to be an
astrophysicist
but none of them had these cues none of
them saw my ambitions they didn't know i
was
head of an astronomy club that i just
created or that i
bought a telescope by walking other
people's dogs and using that to then
create a whole world
that wasn't showing up in the teacher's
classroom and that's who i was and i
knew i was that
so i'm not going to let the the teacher
or the
and and because he got me started here
sorry
i'm just okay and and and and i was
going to tweet this but i think no would
be too controversial i won't but i would
tell you here and now
okay for every student who does not get
an
a on an exam there's a teacher
telling them what they should not be
when they grow up
and i i object
i object to that mode of interaction
between a system that's trying to
educate you and a
person who's trying to figure out what
they want to be when they grow up
okay but isn't there a balance there
neil let's be for real because on the
one hand you don't want to
discourage anyone from being there
or realizing their true potential in
life but on the other hand
there are people who create unrealistic
uh desires and expectations for children
by not telling them uh certain things
like
the the mom who's just like look at you
baby you can sing don't you listen to
them
you can celebrate them
if a note came up and punched it in the
throat
and it's ah oh don't you worry baby you
can sing
so where is that balance
heather say something okay did your
parents tell you you're funny
[Laughter]
no i'm gonna tell you the truth dave you
know what my parents told me more than
anything what
shut up and look at me man
all right say something here you know i
think what we're getting into bail us
out
oh yeah it's the nature nurture kind of
debate and and i do think that there are
certain
let's say genetic predispositions that
people are born with there are studies
that show that for example
musical ability is one of them um some
people are just
born like with perfect pitch and you
know or athletic abilities and
so like i'm never going to be the best
you know basketball player because i'm
not
a certain height let's say perhaps but
given that within our sort of i think
the genetics is what creates our
boundaries perhaps the limitations of of
how high we can go or or low but
the motivation that you were talking
about neil is what
pushes us to our greatest to the height
of where we can go within our genetic
boundaries and so somebody might be born
with a predisposition for a huge
high iq but they never do anything with
it they're not motivated then somebody
else who might have a
lower iq on paper is so motivated
they're at the top of their scale
they're doing way better than that
person with the genetics
that's my whole point that's that's all
i'm trying to say here
okay right of course but but like so
chuck's point with the singing ability
you know that person maybe practice
practice practice and they'll get as
good as they can get
but they just don't have the vocal cords
to get any further but i think the
people who reach the highest heights are
those who have a
genetic ability plus the motivation to
get to
those high heights yeah but i would say
practically every
truly successful person in life in
business and
finance and politics go to every single
one of them and to a
person they will be stories in their
life about people
telling them that they that they won't
succeed or that they should not pursue
they all have these failure stories
and so i just don't want to presume that
it's a given
that someone says oh you'll never be
good at that i'm going to use that as an
excuse to be
even better than you ever thought and
that happened to my father
didn't i tell the story that happened to
my father he was in high school
and then in gym class and and my father
was a
muscular right and the teacher said to
him
look at cyril tyson he has the body that
will never be good at
track because they're about to enter the
track and field unit
of the gym class and my father said to
himself no one is going to tell me what
i
can't be in life he used that as
motivation to take up track
yeah and within five years he was
world class and had the fifth fastest
time
in the world in the event that he
specialized in
so it's examples like that the fact that
that even exists
at all as an example tells me
i don't give a rat's ass about what you
think my genetic limits are
because my ambitions as far as i'm
concerned transcend it all
well it sounds to me like you're making
a case for negative motivation as far as
i'm concerned
as far as i'm concerned if you're a
teacher you should tell a kid they can't
do
anything because then they will go on
and achieve the highest heights of
everything
dave give me some more questions no no
no no
i have to call out my high school
guidance counselor in the context of
this
who because i was a very good student
academically but i attended
occasionally cut class i'm just saying i
was a little you know i could class
occasionally so my guidance counselor
said
i said i need the college applications
at the time there was no online that the
guidance counselor had to give them to
you and he said
don't even bother applying to college
you're never gonna go anywhere anyway
and didn't give me the applications and
i had to drive to the school
myself go to their offices get the
applications physically fill them out
myself no help from the guidance
counselor so i just want to call out
my high school guidance counselor for
giving me the motivation
to excel another is there something
going on in your mind when you get that
negative feedback that
that triggers dopamine or you know some
reaction that
makes some people a lot of people are
like unlike that yeah why do some people
use the negative force as a positive
driver and others
absorb it and then it squashes their
ambitions
what's the difference there that'd be
useful to know if we can harness that
yeah you know that has a lot to do a lot
more to do with with
self-esteem to be honest so people who
have a very high self-esteem
take that criticism and say you know no
thank you
i'm going to show you because i i know
internally i'm better than that
i don't you know but if you don't have
that confidence
you absorb it and it can actually bring
you down
and make you less motivated so i don't
think it works well for everybody that
that's that sort of negative
uh style in that sense um it depends on
how it interacts with your self-esteem
and your confidence
okay can i ask a question for cynthia
basin i know my times tables
because i recited them while i walked to
the bus a half mile from school
each day okay uphill both ways
and uh in the snow in the snow
however the reason why i asked that
question to her
is because that's a rote learning and
then you have like
my kids they don't do that the teachers
do not
give them any wrote it's been falling
out of favor over the years
so what is what's going on there
for both of those things and what are
the
merits of like rote learning versus
other types of
learning well i think there's just
something also with the physical
activity and the rote learning like
sometimes people pace back and forth
um they're they're the motor cortex in
the brain is is close to
other areas of the brain that
instantiate that that um sort of take in
that information
and so there's something about the pace
of moving and walking and learning
cortex of the brain that specifically
means what
motor cortex it it's the part of the
brain
that controls your body movement there's
like a strip
of the brain um that controls all the
body movements and it's right
part of the pre just in the sort of back
part of the prefrontal cortex where a
lot of the
higher level learning takes place so
they're very intimately connected and so
you stimulate one part of the brain and
because they're all connected it starts
to stimulate the other parts that you
need to use for thinking um
so that's one thing and in terms of
memorization look i think there
there is something to that just
practicing rote memory at some level
because
it it's teaching your brain it's it's
sort of gearing up those connections
so that you can better have a better
memory in general
so i don't i'm not against rote
memorization i just don't i think that
that can be a piece
of learning but not the entire you know
there needs to be a richer
context with for that information to be
absorbed another
there's a really good related
questionnaire this is way in the
beginning and it was from
uh eduardo arugio prader i hope i have
that right
and he's asking you specifically is
there any study about the impact of
technology
and learning on the brain and i just
want to expand on a little bit it's like
you know how
sports technology has transformed sports
in many ways
how does technology transform
transformed learning
absolutely i mean now you know in the
classrooms
i mean well depending on the school
obviously what they have access to
but you know they're giving kids like
ipads now to learn on and they're
they're using they're trying to
incorporate these techniques in the
classroom
well wait heather let me make this more
controversial there are entire
educational philosophies
that reject the infusion of technology
into the classroom
on the grounds that somehow it will
disrupt
what would be an authentic learning
environment
so what would you say to these
educational philosophies
that are at odds with what role
technology might or could play
in this whole enterprise so like
anything else that
sort of humans create i think it's in
how we use it
so if we use it as a tool that is
interactive with a real human not a
replacement
for you know because the best learning
happens interactively
with real humans i think but you can
supplement it
with these tools and depending on how we
use it it could be of course for
good or evil um you know and so you know
the answer is kind of both right
depending on how it's used
it could be a detriment or it could be
something that you know bolsters up
our education and i think we're in still
in that early stage of trying to figure
out what the best
how the best way to incorporate
technology into the classroom is and we
still don't quite know
all things considered the technology is
a relatively new thing in the history of
education
right so i i wouldn't be surprised if it
did take
one or two generations to get the bugs
out well then education
adapts technologically technology
technology
slowly slower than you know consumers do
so
yeah they take even longer right yeah
absolutely so you know pedro silva says
this
uh kids use too much video games and
these video games
can be used to teach physics used with
some help from kids to understand
more um was an angry birds
test a lot of physics knowledge i think
uh angry birds
i mean there are some video games that
use more cognitive abilities than others
i would think
right heather yeah i mean look there are
certain
you know things kids can pick up from
video games there's like speed of
processing speed
and and it's paying attention to
multiple things but
but i think there are even better ways
to use the technology and that sort of
gamification way
you know like my daughter it was using
this thing um
with coding but you know you code this
like friendly robot to go through these
adventures and so there's like
motivation there
to learn the coding you know making it
fun you're actually learning a skill set
but you're doing it while creating or
playing this game
and i think that kind of integration of
technology is
is creative and can be really helpful
rather than just sitting there playing
you know
i don't know angry birds or something
well you can still get something out of
angry birds but
here's a definite consequence of the
video game era
is that when i was growing up you to be
accused of being all thumbs
meant you were clumsy now all thumbs
meant you were quite dexterous
on on a video game that you don't hear
i'm all thumbs anymore that's just one
so what about time for just a couple
more questions before we finish out the
hour
you said earlier that you know actually
doing something it helps
uh cement things in your memory uh
somehow
but also too is is that innate you know
um
i've seen things like you everybody
knows you put a toddler
on you know in their high chair and the
first thing they do is they throw their
cheerios on the floor
and are they are they testing gravity
are they testing newton's law of
gravitation i mean are they
experimenting
and do we know that could we know that
right yes and you know i'm going to
recommend um
a book called the scientist in the crib
by a developmental psychologist alison
gotnik
who which covers all this research um
just
just that saying these things that
toddlers are doing
are are experimenting and learning
physics
yes they are learning about gravity
they're all all of it
um and so like you know i was saying
before if you can scale that
up to the adult brain now and create a
new interactive obviously we've picked
up on a lot of the
um physics through our experience over
time
and now we need to create big you know
large exhibitions or whatever it may be
that make us continue to be curious
about the world around us
what do you mean when you say scale up
you mean just more
yellow in terms of of size and
well not necessarily size but creativity
so maybe for an adult it is
um the the experience is how do we
figure out with all these pieces how to
build this robot you know and you have
to start up trying to figure it out
whereas as a kid you're using legos to
understand how things fit together yeah
dave i think when she meant
what she said scale up she meant at some
point
take the teenager out of the high chair
put them in another kind of environment
and i just want to push back mildly on
you
if you're if your toddler pushes the
cheerios to the floor
and does not watch it fall they're not
doing a science experiment they're not
doing the same
they're just they're just saying f you
making a mess
when they throw it in your face
that's not physics that's a whole other
thing by the way
by the way the best the best joke i ever
heard about uh baby cognition was
where we were on a plane and a baby
would not stop crying
it just kept crying so violently and
uh a guy said god that baby must be
really annoying to that mother and then
i said no what if that baby is crying
because he knows we're on the wrong
approach vector
and he does not have language to tell us
yet
[Laughter]
that's a that would be a weird sci-fi
storytelling
babies like a little bit they're they're
actually
that we do make this analogy they're
kind of like what adult brain is like on
psychedelics
in a way that their filter system they
haven't developed the filter system of
the brain so everything
is coming in it's unstructured and
everything feels new
and interesting and exciting so people
often describe that when they're
on these psychedelics like whoa look at
my hands or you know everything looks
different interesting they're trying to
figure it out so that's why adults are
not intrigued by
someone dangling keys in front of them
whereas a kid
we got to land this plane to follow the
analogy there
um but heather it's always great to have
you on star talk and thanks for
giving your time not only to star talk
but for this virtual
conference for teachers and it's always
great when we know exactly who our
audience is because
that can fine-tune all that we have to
share with them
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure and i'd have to give my
official sign off which is i'm neil
degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist bidding
you
to keep looking up
you